a lion air Boeing 737 crashed into the
sea this morning rescuers have located
debris but they do not expect to find
any survivors some of the warning signs
you know in retrospect we're there all
along some of the decisions or changes
were so subtle that people might not
even have realized the importance as
they were taking place the Ethiopian
Airlines flight has crashed shortly
after takeoff from addis ababa killing
all 157 passengers and crew thought to
be on board Boeing's best-selling plane
is coming under increased scrutiny after
another deadly and accident we'll do
everything possible to earn and re earn
that trust and confidence from our
customers and the flying public in the
weeks and months ahead Boeing is an
American icon revered around the world
for its engineering innovation but with
two crashes in under six months
critics have asked if Boeing is straying
from its original mission the SEC is
investigating whether Boeing properly
disclosed issues tied to the grounding
of its 737 max airliners one message
described the 737 max as a plane
designed by clowns overseen by monkeys
the safety culture at Boeing was
corrupted under pressure from Wall
Street and executives and board members
who were looking more at their bonuses
than they were at the integrity of the
organization Boeing was playing a game
to a certain extent it was a game of
numbers they were meeting Wall Street's
expectations but unfortunately that came
at the expense of the end customer and
the flying public the failures that
happened at Boeing are really
complicated and involves subtle forces
and cultural changes that have been
underway for decades at the company this
is a story of how an American icon lost
its way and whether or not it can find
it again
20:19 was not the best year for Boeing
just five months apart two Boeing 737
max planes crashed and the planes have
been grounded since March of 2019
there's simply no precedent in aviation
for a plane this important to be
grounded this log in the first crash
line Air flight 610 something was
discovered with the technology on the
plane investigators believe the plane
sensors or it's computers had bad data
suggesting a potential stall there was
this software system known as M Cass
that stands for maneuvering
characteristics augmentation system
this obscure flight control software was
created so the max handled the same way
for pilots as the previous generation of
737s black box data indicated that a bad
sensor had triggered M casts which
automatically pushed the plane down
within probably 24 hours of them
discovering this Boeing and the FAA put
out a warning indicating that this could
occur and then also telling them how to
counteract it there is a fix simply
flipping a switch should have turned the
automatic system off the second crash
however the same failure I've covered
dozens and dozens of plane crashes and
one of my mantras has always been that
crashes don't occur for the same cause
China grounded the plane and it just set
off a ripple effect any plane currently
in the air will go to its destination
and thereafter be grounded Boeing is an
incredible company and hopefully they'll
very quickly come up with the answer
what it had been build is a relatively
simple software fix proved not to be so
simple every time is he like Boeing was
just around the corner then you know a
new issue cropped up MCATs wasn't the
only issue on this airplane you had
issues where the computers were getting
overloaded with information now there's
a new issue that the computers don't
start up properly when you want them to
and then the first batch of really
embarrassing employee emails leaked the
FAA is demanding answers from Boeing
after they waited months to disclose to
the agency internal messages between
test pilots who were working in the 737
max flight simulator it's running
rampant in the sim on me one pilot
referencing the flight simulator the
plane is trimming itself like crazy the
emails came out two weeks before
Boeing's chief executive Denis
Wallenberg was due to testify before
Congress and it was a bipartisan shell
aking 346 people are dead because what
these chief pilots described as
egregious you're the CEO the buck stops
with you did you read this document and
how did your team not put it in front of
you run in with their hair on fire
saying we got a real problem here you
know ultimately we don't quite know
exactly what caused the MCATs design
just like we don't know all the causes
of the crash we don't quite know but
it's very clear that the one big
cultural change in Boeing had been a
well a disruption in the communication
between engineers and top management but
this kind of cultural change for
companies old as Boeing happens slowly
over the course of not years but decades
Boeing's history goes back over a
century and while as early sea planes
weren't iconic by World War two their
military aircraft were successful raid
but applying fortresses comes in these
are the people who get the biggest
thrill the thousands of Boeing workers
who build the Boeing's an American
manufacturing icon it was was churning
out bombers that were critical to the
Allied defense effort and gave us Rosie
the Riveter sort of a symbol of American
can-do culture employers find that women
can do many jobs as well as men
some jobs better they were the great
survivors of the post-world War two
shakedown in aircraft design and the
most successful new entrant in the new
jetliner market of the late
fifties the company gambled everything
on a prototype of what became its first
jetliner
the Boeing 707 nearing completion in the
Boeing plant in Seattle America's first
jet transport is a unit of glistening
beauty that was followed by the 727 and
built this revolutionary behemoth the
747 you you probably know it for the
hump behind the nose and at the same
time they came up with what became
Boeing's greatest commercial success and
that was the 737 the 737 wasn't
immediately successful it took several
design and engineering iterations to
turn it into the plane that we see today
became a workhorse for airlines you know
like Southwest that fly primarily
shorter routes and really brought travel
to everyday people and even as more and
more travelers flew on these aircraft
the aviation safety record during this
time made flying one of the
statistically safest ways to travel
we've been the technology leader in
aviation in the world a Boeing was a
magnificent company who made in my
opinion the best airplanes in the world
until some of these recent cultural
changes which all came from pressure to
Wall Street and bad management you know
over the years Boeing was this
tremendously important and innovative
company but it wasn't necessarily a
great stock in 1997 Boeing merged with
McDonnell Douglas another aerospace and
defense giant Boeing said let's do a
merger we'll continue with the
innovation and maybe McDonnell Douglas
will help us in terms of our structure
and telling our story to Wall Street
almost immediately I began to hear kind
of a bitter joke coming out of Seattle
that McDonnell Douglas had used Boeing's
money to buy Boeing
and certainly in terms of management
structure it began to look that way
Harry Stonecipher a former GE executive
and McDonnell Douglas CEO becomes CEO o
of the combined companies in more and
more of the company's style and culture
began to be more of an McDonnell Douglas
sort of the picture he almost
immediately sort of signaled there was a
new sheriff in town and he was going to
bring financial discipline to Boeing
Stonecipher would eventually become CEO
and continued his emphasis on
controlling costs within the company a
culture that engineers within the
company would begin to feel we had
breakfast with the president of the
commercial this is dance torture he was
a physicist at Boeing for over 20 years
and felt these changes firsthand and he
said he was so proud of cutting his
capital expenditure budgets by 60%
capital expenditures for us were
improvements in the factory in the shop
floor in processes and materials and
things like that by 2000 there was a
great deal of dissatisfaction with the
way our problem-solving culture was
being displaced and we thought it was
just much more difficult for us to do
our job and that's when a lot of people
traced this sort of fundamental shift in
thinking in terms of what you prioritize
whether that be profits or whether that
be engineering further evidence of a
move away from engineering prowess and
innovation to profit was Boeing's
decision to move company headquarters to
Chicago when Boeing's jet manufacturing
and airplane designers were in Seattle
probably the biggest motivation was to
send a message to the street that this
was a company that was not going to make
investment decisions on the basis of
legacy or heritage or anything like that
but rather purely make investment
decisions on the basis of returns and by
moving to a place where there were no
legacy loyalties no heritage production
facilities they were sending that
message and it also started to shape how
Boeing viewed its own internal
investments in things like airplane
programs
endlessly important as the company
started planning for what became the 787
dreamliner for this this event it was
held on July 8 2007 so 787 tom brokaw
was there I was there I'm just sitting
in the audience just trying to soak it
all in
I think they raised the factory door and
there was the plane but at the time it
was just it was an empty shell we didn't
know it but it was all for appearances
for the 787 Boeing attempted a new
system for designing the aircraft
instead of doing everything in-house it
would outsource much of the planes
design and manufacturing to its biggest
suppliers it was going to be about
outsourcing outsourcing to the places
where we could produce things more
cheaply as opposed to the finest best
safest airplanes in the world which is
what Boeing made for decades this works
for running shoes ladies garments cell
phones hard drives integrated circuits
it works for everybody gonna work for
you and I thought no it won't Boeing had
never done a plane using the system
before this was very different from you
know Boeing controlling the processes
itself and it did not go well we
launched the 787 the worst I could think
of was that we'd be three months late
which is a shooting offence at Boeing it
wasn't three months late it was three
years late it wasn't five billion
dollars over budget it was 30 or 40 or
50 billion dollars over budget grounded
the fleet for three months the suppliers
you know we're just in over their heads
most of them we had years of issues
there was an engine explosion at one
point there was a an electrical fire on
a flight test aircraft and I thought
okay this experiment is done
this didn't work and the executives said
the business model is fine we just
didn't execute it every new airplane has
growing pains especially those that kind
of push the edge of the envelope and
technology eventually Boeing would fix
many of the 787's issues and the
Dreamliner slowly started to bring in
big returns and with a profitable plane
boeing looked at other measures to boost
its returns to shareholders there's
different ways of getting your profit up
so one is just that you make the best
product imaginable and everybody wants
to buy it and so your sales go up and
you make more money on that plane the
other is that you do financial
engineering one common technique for
companies to boost their stock price is
a practice known as stock buybacks where
a company uses its capital to buy back
its own stock from the marketplace and
the math is really simple to understand
if you have fewer shares trading you
know absent all else the price goes up
the shares worth more they get a nice
return on their investment Boeing stock
was on the rise and by 2015 new CEO
Dennis Muhlenberg would ramp the program
up even more from 2014 to 2019 Boeing
would repurchase about 38 billion of its
own shares they went from a relatively
normal percentage something like 30%
it's over 90 percent of cash being
returned to investors and the contrast
to pensions being cut was really
shocking and sort of a bitter moment for
some people buying back shares and
paying huge dividends while you're
laying off senior engineers to hire
cheap labor in India that's a sickness
but while longtime employees at Boeing
may have been frustrated at the time
this was viewed as a huge success in
less than a decade the company's stock
price tripled Wall Street just loved
this company its stock shot up I see a
new Boeing I see just straight-line
growth and Muhlenberg was getting the
rock star treatment you're obviously a
very accomplished exec you've done a
great job for Boeing and its
shareholders like
I had bought the stock when you look
over but it's still a good deal still
the deal around the same time all of
this was happening Boeing was selling
record numbers of its newest plane the
737 max the 737 max was born out of a
competition with Airbus the aviation
industry is a duopoly between Boeing and
Airbus with the two giants controlling
almost all of the jetliner market for
both companies it's beating commercial
heart is an enormous ly profitable
family of single-aisle jets the Boeing
737 and Airbus a320 while Boeing had
planned to build an all-new jet to
replace the 737 it was sidetracked by
the Dreamliner debacle Airbus shocked
everyone by announcing a simple upgrade
to its a320 family of planes and what
became known as the a320neo since the
new planes had engines that increased
fuel efficiency and required no lengthy
training for pilots to fly it became a
huge cost saver for Airlines and a big
hit for Airbus so Boeing had to do the
same thing if Boeing didn't act or
waited too long they could lose
significant market share
American Airlines called Boeing and said
we're gonna buy 400 planes and they will
all be airbus unless you can match their
fuel economy and the fact that no pilot
training is required it's identical to
their other Airbus models and the Boeing
CEO said no no no we'll match that we
want half that order with the max Boeing
was also trying to shake the image of
incompetence that had followed that 787
debacle so there was a lot of pressure
there to show that the hey look we can
design planes and we can meet deadlines
with the max and to their credit with
the max they did
unfortunately for Boeing some of the
critical engineering decisions that were
made came back to haunt them in late
2015 Boeing's first 737 max takes shape
right on schedule
flight testing begins in early 2016 and
in 2017 the max
enters the commercial market months
early and it is in fact the fastest
selling aircraft in company history you
saw huge orders coming for both
companies airlines seemed generally
pleased with it and to be honest they
still are even after the crisis some of
the biggest customers say you know what
this is a good airplane but internal
emails made public from investigators
revealed that Boeing had gone to
extraordinary measures to get the max
into the air including some employees
lying to the FAA the chief technical
pilot on the plane described how he used
Jedi mind tricks on regulators in one
exchange a Boeing employee says I still
haven't been forgiven by God for the
covering up I did last year the most
disturbing thing we've found is there
was a 2013 meeting and they conspired to
conceal this system and Kass was created
so that the larger more fuel-efficient
engines on the max wouldn't make the
plane handle any differently than the
previous generation of 737s at that
meeting they said we'll wait a minute
wait a minute if we tell anybody about
this system then they might right
require that pilots have additional
training and our bosses from the top in
Boeing and our contracts with the
airlines say no additional training
required so we have to conceal this no
one outside Boeing can know that this
safety critical system exists another
week another shake-up at Boeing the
company's former CEO Dennis Muhlenberg
forced out after 35 years with the
company and four years as CEO after
firing Muhlenberg Boeing would close the
books on one of the worst financial
performances in history estimating
eighteen point six billion in total
costs for the grounded 737 max and it
would report its first annual loss since
1997 Dave Calhoun a member of Boeing's
board was tapped as the next CEO and
immediately starts to make sweeping
changes within the company the first
couple of weeks on the job he moved very
quickly to get any embarrassing overhang
from the last year you know just like
clean out the cobwebs get all the bad
news out there right now
trying to be more transparent calhoun
dumped even more damning documents and
holds a conference call with reporters
when hordes reach a conclusion to change
a CEO they expect change and they
recognize the arguments that have been
presented from the outside world as
legit and they're going to experience a
different style of leadership a
different way of doing things but it's
unclear whether or not calhoun will
shift Boeing's priority away from
pleasing Wall Street and return the
company to its engineering roots and
heritage of creating top flight planes
we believe this airplanes safer than the
safest airplane flying today every next
airplane has to be that way it has to be
that way for Boeing it has to be wet
that way for our competitors he's been
on the board since mid-2009
and also one of the well almost all the
board members that do not have an
engineering degrees from a purely
accounting background private equity
hedge funds that kind of thing this is a
bit strange because on one level the
company really needs to change the other
hand other than a shareholder emergency
I'm not really sure what would be the
instigator of that change we are going
to have the most open book the world's
ever seen on this subject
transparency is what we lost for a
moment and it's something we have to
regain because it speaks to the trust
that the world has in us I am very
hopeful that he can restore the safety
culture there so that they can focus on
making safe airplanes the old days is
simply harvesting cash from legacy
programs and returning it to
shareholders need to stop and the idea
of engineers being some sort of
commodity that you can rely upon to come
through for you that needs to stop to
you know the bigger issue of setting the
tone changing culture which you know
these things happen gradually bit by bit
he's saying all the right things right
now about correcting course but we won't
know for awhile as to whether Boeing's
on the right course
you